good morning greetings at 3 gonzález and
these are the most important news
for today thursday february 18 firefighters
fought a fire east of the
valley in the wetlands park that started
on wednesday at around 7 in the
afternoon and remained active for  several hours of the
night the blaze could be seen from
various points of the city and
destroyed at least 10 acres of land no one
was injured and there was no damage to
structures the cause of the fire is
still under investigation and the
governor became active  new directive on
Wednesday that will allow schools that
are offering in-person learning
for at least 20 days to increase
the capacity allowed by the campus by 75 percent
plus
school bus capacity to 65 percent
all students must be at
least three feet  distance between them
and adults will remain six
feet apart as far as exercise
students will not be required to tr  aer
masks worn during
physical education classes or recess
the governor also updated the
guidelines for contact sports and
student sports said that sports in
schools can continue but
only for those that belong
to the nevada association of inter-
academic activities better known
as em
For its acronym in English, the governor
asked the association to
develop a stricter plan to
contain the spread of the corona virus
and with the return to face-
to-face classes for students from pre-kindergarten to
third grade, the school district is
hiring guards for crossings  school
applicants must be at least 18
years old and will undergo an
agility screening and criminal background check
positions pay up to $15 per hour
and there are hundreds of open positions
throughout the valley to apply you can
visit our website or
our  social networks let's see
how the temperatures will be  For the
weekend it will be sunny days with a
bit of wind today we will have a maximum
of 58 degrees and for next week
we will be seeing temperatures of 70
degrees this information is to be
an excellent day andrés gonzález informed them
and this was
about news now news in spanish
[Music]